yo what is up everybody I am prestige
and what oh don't know for the pins on
the inside up look inside no no he gone
with you begone with you foul demon okay
I think will be good for now alright
guys my name is prestige and I got a
little end is right there that is the
first first sighting of the new model
but and I put in the mod a divine RPG
which is I'd say one of the most amazing
thorough mods I've ever seen and so
again to that later you're also probably
wondering what is all this I finished I
extra building since I just did some oh
and this roof tire oh gosh all the
changes I didn't make sure work because
I wanted a takeaway I wanted the this
episode to be more about exploring the
new modern stuff and if I had to build
all the stuff it wouldn't have been
about it so we're gonna want to get rid
of this I also got the mod damage
indicators because it shows me like how
much damage I'm doing and how much stuff
there so let's okay we want that we
don't want that creeper get a grody mess
so you put the way tell aboard yeah
that's an end or spider so we have a few
new end we have you know end villains we
have a few new nether villains and we
have a lot more dimensions so let's go
die oh you do a lot it wow he did three
hearts of damage with a full set of iron
come on up so teleporting a noob okay
well this is going to be difficult um I
think I'll be able to sleep but yeah
let's sleep hopefully doesn't teleport
name
so he seems to have the ability to
teleport please not till I porn in here
and so since this is a wooden door I
have a temporary long system so it's
cool okay it seems to hear a little
friend over there let's get out of the
house let's just get far away this from
the stuff we don't want destroyed again
you see we got we got the king crabs
over here those are generally thought
begun see iron sword only has six damage
no oh look at that dodge heard that
creeper and blue locks so for this stuff
like eventually the overworld is going
to be nothing and I'm going to be able
to kill it with everything because the
stuff we get into has so much help and
like the weapons are so strong that
these things all die one hit like you
see the king crab has 500 health that is
over twice the health of the Enderdragon
so energizing really isn't that big of a
deal anymore and okay i think mr.
Anderson has disappeared so that they
did add a few i do not have gems mod
anymore because there are many like I
thought it would just get too confusing
which it would it doesn't there aren't
like tons of new oars in this world
there's only three and the real mites
are the might and rupees and so that's
not much but there's so much other armor
and stuff that I think well I think you
guys would be fun that so I'm just
trying to decide how we want to do that
I can only get real Knight but to get
real night I need to it's really rare
like all these orders are really rare
and I don't think they spawned these
chunks because these chunks already
loaded so we're gonna need to make a
spawner and real a mite and the spawner
because there are things i drop really
might so i'm going to want to take this
all the way down here and i'm gonna
wanna
I don't block this ok I'm going to block
this off just so I can continue my
staircase and have I'm going to make
this air case because I'm going to make
a few spawners because that's the
spawners are the best way to get the
materials from certain things some iron
but yeah iron like real a mite which is
considered a week armor is a higher
class than iron so iron is basically
going to become useless so yeah just
letting you all you people know just
break you because I don't like how the I
guess I missed that and I missed you ok
I think we should be good for now get a
little bit of high ceiling there ok so
yeah are the certain things that spawn
arla might not are the right arm is
awesome certain things saying the things
that spawned Rilla might like monsters
that you kill our spawn low and one of
them spawns in all light which is really
good because I can have a light at so
other mobs will spawn and that's cool
yos oh frick offered that thing I know
that thing is that that sound that you
just heard if you may I finish here if
you can pick it up and go go back in the
video on you'll hear it like right oh
that is the strongest melee type there
it is again mob in the overworld so
that's something to be scared of um
well there we have we're at 15 so
technically it we should be able to make
the spawner here i'm going to get my tnt
because that'll make things quicker
indeed indeed they let us go look dupa
dupa dupa do coal is still going to be
just as vital just saying so yes the
first thing we're gonna want to do is
probably go into the nether and then the
end why I saw this there's like this
starting guide for a divine RPG oh there
we go that is a cyclops now see the this
model so the damage indicator also tells
me what type of my optus is so he will
not attack me if I don't attack him now
I'm not going to attack him he's my soul
ward 26 damage and he is 400 health so
if you're a logical person you can see
how that they're not a good idea artwork
why is gonna pattern here we actually
make more cutie but we're gonna make
some Flint and stale to light this bad
boy off finish tail there we go and back
down yeah
to lift a paper a baby Oh someone is
taking some hardcore damage over there I
read and place and place auntie Alice
O'Hara me love actually surprised by
that okay yeah I can always like make
Nick this blocked off and stuff what the
heck is that uh that's my desire give me
lying give me you on it son so yeah this
kind of preparation I should you get you
guys saw few mobs and will also be I
think Hank three high is good so let's
go to view the TNT is gonna use part 1
on wasting tea house a large box
rockaway so big
oh my gosh so much cravo you got on with
you travel hey know what that was bad
but at least it's not I remember this
was obviously in the pc version by
played xbox version before and yeah this
coal is going to I'm going to CD um but
when you ever you replacing tu would
light it with your hand so if you placed
it you were screwed because we're gonna
blow up so I'm that I wasn't fun oh well
that gives us another up cats ice gravel
made things easier on us but as I said I
only need three highs and also going to
please and I were to see you walk I sure
hope she just said a one to the side all
right whatever I can just mind so let's
turn that music down a bit boo boo boo
make myself spawner of good people that
place you and say off and I can place
one and yes sister damn sure I didn't
put a torch nice just break this you
something to have a so start tickets to
get in that direction boo boo I'll
probably do a lot of work on this out
off camera but this is gonna like
showing you guys like will be up to and
now let's see if we do one there we can
do one there yeah no one there I doing
there so boom boom boom sure don't want
you blowing down the street though so
one more and place one more plate wait
no bad place you here we lapis to bet I
don't want lapis and one more and
Wow dayum on that's cool hope none
you're blown up and right now a diamond
is still are really good for us so Oh
Frick was that yeah like okay oh my
keepers freaking out one sec stop stop
stop stop there we go okay then I'll
just block that all stop I heard that
when i was in creative mode before I've
no idea what the freaking noises stop it
stop it you know lease the things that
like a 16 by 16 hole will be good so
I'll go for that and it sounds like it
was all under this oh my gosh and lots
of times oh my gosh feel like I thing's
gonna like come out and tak me okay good
stop you're annoying and no one likes
you oh my gosh I guess you don't care
okay I'm gonna just take the pic
poo poo dude dude you do god of its
gonna be there also whales in this
that's cool how big is this one up
123456789 yannick airfares off i'll give
their skirt screw the dirt oh my gosh
nice yeah run it up man I'm the bays I
their light back here his torch hitman
well oh my gosh that is annoying here
are some mobs
okay you not me someone sign I'll return
to do this busy works and let's see how
long how long have I been recording wow
there's almost over dang it sorry this
was not that entertaining video tribe
leg our first rider will do something
about all the goods and noe and lapine
poopy crap probably isn't close enough
for it to spawn dang it whatever go you
guess I'm sitting in your building to
nether let's deposit the goods I don't
want that for now just throw all this
stuff in here no I don't bother you
since I did want to get a sub city in
we're done doing that so there we go
okay oh yeah if you're wondering about
dokucraft yeah I can get that I mean I'm
in 1.47 since uh RPG hasn't been
upgraded for
well this isn't alone
or whatever I'll fix it later RPG has
been upgraded for 157 so we're zombie in
food Gordon ama I was going to get us
some obsidian that is here from going to
have a when we see those other module Oh
Frick you guys hear that this mom is
freaking scary bro what okay here love
so here I'll see your water so okay
there we go there's already some pre
obsidian a halls are yours a spider so
your your new one day I'm is awesome
seadream be dead okay and then we need
to stop you light this up a little bit I
know oh so no one shows up no no
unwanted guests show up especially when
I'm mine obsidian grow why is there love
under this
nope seems that we're good here's
skeleton but guess what we should chill
without him oh I can I want to get
enough obsidian to build an enchantment
table and another portal so yeah Wow hi
was mining diamond before with an
efficiency pics of this is frickin going
yeah well I get for upsetting that's
enough for in enchantment table I can't
return for the other city where the heck
did I come in from yeah okay yeah the
thing that I'm trying to spawn swans in
full light so might as well do my best
to make it nice and bright think that's
pretty full lady oh yeah that's the
thing that I heard before loud demonic
noise up there as you can I'm gonna run
my sword out you gotta sort one too much
oh well me me me
this is a normal spider or the end drop
normal we got a ten cricket next lesson
you make a boat you guys might do do do
do do we need books and yeah that's all
we need Oh need some guns hope don't
want to drop that but diamond diamond
absolute on book enchantment table and
let's turn the rest of the books on the
bookshelves right now
Wow for that's going to give us some
legit enchantments bro all right um
should be a long episode so accept
accept it and like it just rode right
here
click build outs
oh yeah you know surrounding Kabul so
chairman tables gonna be there so that
means book shows that this pixels shirt
she's not dirt these bookshelves have to
go there it goes yes I got no shells go
here that we're also going to need
bookshelves right here it's really
madness episode and books will fit here
so that means I don't want all this cowl
some you you
now bookshelf ill to go there now all
right we have the outline of all the
bookshelves probably want this to be da
kabul yeah
for some added security and I guess I
guess this will work so i wanted i do
wanna hire roof bum bum
I'm confusing what I'm doing um just do
that I don't really need know why I'm
doing this butts
except that it's cool what type of
enchantment I get use it online pick
let's go five efficiency one yeah the
best the best for ho oh my gosh yeah I
efficiency wanna smell too good okay
well yesterday in the episode here I
guess it will all right well guys I hope
you enjoyed the episode even those are
literally kind of weird and funky my
name is teach you like this video
comment like and subscribe if you're new
you got all the way to the end of this
video I think the video deserves it and
up we need that string to make a bow
right right right there we go uh he's
not guys